We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I'm getting more and more emails, voicemails,
tweets, as my goatee has filled in.
Still pathetically, but it has there are lots
of people who are not pleased with it.
Take a listen to this.
OK, David Pakman.
Yeah, Tom is from Austin calling sounding
the alarm.
Yeah.
We don't need to go into this kind of go to
say that I see happening now, I'm very happy
about your vitamin D levels.
Thank you.
But to go to it, it's not going to work.
You've got to go clean shaven, looking good,
like a news man.
Yeah.
So, listen, I am not a newsman.
I am merely an analyst, a commentator.
So there's no editor telling me I need to
be clean shaven, but it's not going to last
that much longer.
My girlfriend has already put in her complaint
about it and it's not going.
I think I will probably do one show with just
a handlebar mustache and then it'll be gone.
I know this is not very important, but in
a time when so much is happening, that is
extraordinarily disturbing.
Why not talk about one more disturbing thing,
which is my inability to grow serious facial
hair.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I am so glad to see that New England Patriots
coach Bill Belichick is not going to be moving
forward with receiving the Presidential Medal
of Freedom from Donald Trump.
Very glad to see it.
We will talk about that and much more on the
bonus show.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.